a New Jersey police officer will not
face charges for punching a woman in the
head during a controversial arrest that
was caught on video we all saw this
widely shared cell phone footage shows
one officer pinning down 20 year old
Emily Wyman as another hits her several
times the Cape May County Prosecutor's
Office says the actions of the officer
do new do not rather warrant criminal
charges Wyman though faces several
charges including assault and she's now
speaking publicly about this very
unfortunate incident
David beg no sat down with her and her
attorney last night for their first TV
interview David I can't wait to hear
what she has to say she was all too
happy to talk came here into New York
and said ask me whatever you want to ask
okay so we did good morning Emily
Wineman does have a prior criminal
history she is currently on probation
for misdemeanors simple assault in
another jurisdiction look she admits
she's not perfect but she says her
action in this case was only human in my
eyes I'm not a criminal I'm not a bad
person
Emily Wineman says she stands by her
actions Memorial Day weekend after
Wildwood New Jersey police officers
attempted to cite her for possessing
alcohol at the beach have you been
drinking no I was and were any of the
alcohol containers around you open no
the 20 year old Philadelphia woman
willingly took two breathalyzer tests
both came back negative I'm like you
guys have anything better to do there's
so much stuff going on you know and
you're trying to stop people for
underage drinking and you see I didn't
drink he was like that's it I was gonna
let you go but now I'm gonna write you
up I stayed calm you know a little
attitude but I mean not really
steven dick is women's attorney he
hadn't told her that she had committed
any crime he hadn't told her I'm gonna
issue you with summons he hadn't told
her any of those things and then he said
oh you're about to get dropped moments
later the officers body camera shows him
on top of wine
he then appears to hit her repeatedly a
bystander also caught the moment on
their cellphones the officer can later
be heard on the body camera explaining
his use of force
she tried kicking at us so he slammed
her on the ground she kicked him the
police are saying you resisted so why
not just stop and argue with them in
court later it's it's it's impossible to
answer that question realizing possible
because it's all happening in the moment
Lymon is also charged with spitting at
the officer it looks like you spit at
the officer I got the sand in my mouth
so when he that smashed my head into the
ground I had all this sand in my mouth
when they got me on my stomach I turned
around I meant to go spit it out what's
your reaction to the announcement the
officers won't be charged they think
that because they're cops they could get
away with it and that's not the case
that's not right at all do you feel like
you owe the officers an apology honestly
no I don't I'm just like I said I'm
sorry that I heard he's very sorry that
the situation happened but I don't know
them apology at all so when we wrapped
up that interview we called Wyman's what
we actually talked to the attorney and
then reached out to the police chief at
Wildwood and also the mayor they did not
return our calls Wyman is charged with
two counts of aggravated assault on a
police officer spitting at an officer
disorderly conduct resisting arrest and
being a minor in possession of alcohol
look guys here's the deal the attorney
says bottom line she might not have
acted in the way that we all like but
she didn't have to cooperate with the
Brussel
breathalyzer and she didn't have to give
her name so the attorney says in the
beginning she was not being detained she
did this willingly but didn't have to
cooperate I'm so looking at Miss Emily
the spitting about spitting sin I mean
all of it it just looks bad it just
looks bad she seems like there was a way
that everybody could have handled it
better with there's enough blame to go
around on both sides it was the waiver
they were willing under she wasn't
exactly a bruiser yeah thank you thanks
David